good afternoon and welcome welcome to
the Hillsdale College L&P Kirby jr.
center for constitutional studies and
citizenship into this first principles
on first Friday's lecture which is part
of the monthly lecture series that
addresses significant and timely
political historical and economic topics
from a constitutional perspective my
name is Tim Casper and I served as
associate vice president for external
affairs at the college where I also
teach in the politics department I'm
pinch-hitting today for my colleague and
friend David Bob who usually hosts these
lectures David and his lovely wife Anne
are expecting their second child so we
had to attend to more important matters
the Caribbean centre marks an extension
of Hillsdale college's commitment to the
Constitution through teaching the
enduring principles of the American
Declaration of Independence and
constitution the kirby center seeks to
inspire citizens students teachers
policymakers and elected officials to
return those principles to their central
place in American political life now I
can't help but mention that today's
lecture topic reminds me of Ronald
Reagan's famous warning about the ten
most dangerous words in the English
language hi I'm from the government and
I'm here to help of course Reagan's joke
as usual has a serious point a point he
made memorably in his first inaugural
that rule by bureaucratic experts
eventually replaces rule by consent
sorry ruled by the people or government
by consent the longer this goes on the
harder it becomes to recover the
founders Constitution to help us think
more clearly about our current crisis we
have invited well an expert but I'm
happy to say she's not here to try and
rule you but merely to offer advice for
a country in need of it to introduce her
i'll ask hillsdale college student brad
Dietzen to come forward brad as a senior
class of 22
self and has been interning at the kirby
center this summer Brett veronique de
rosa is a senior research fellow at the
Mercatus Center she was previously a
resident fellow at the american
enterprise institute a policy analyst at
the Cato Institute and a research fellow
at the Atlas Economic Research
Foundation her areas of expertise
include the federal budget Homeland
Security taxation tax competition and
financial privacy issues she writes a
column for Reason magazine and is a
regular contributor to the American she
also blogs at the corner at national
review online and at big government dr.
Davies I earned an MA in economics from
the university of paris dauphine and a
PhD in economics from the university of
paris sorbonne today dr. Davies I will
be speaking on the timely and pressing
topic of the debt limit increase please
join me in welcoming dr. david zhang
hi everyone that's it's a real pleasure
to be here I I wanted to first tell you
that I've been to Hillsdale at someone I
had aspiration to actually teach at
Hillsdale and I was like it was
Hillsdale or nothing and then I decided
you know that really mean teaching maybe
was not for me I was just you know and
the think tank World was better but i
can tell you i mean i really really
considered really hard hillsdale because
it seems to be kind of just a phenomenal
you know place to to teach so now the
topic of this talk the debt ceiling so
as the debt ceiling showdown heads to
its final stage everyone is seeking to
gains to against the battle of public
relations waar right lawmakers of course
they feel a lot of pressure because the
stakes are really high confrontation
like this one of this sword become the
defining moment of a political life that
distinguishes statesmen from near
politicians but as harry truman state is
a statesman it's just a politician who's
been dead for 15 years
what doesn't often happen however is the
opportunity to correct a deep chronic
problem and that's the real reason maybe
the only reason why actually this debt
ceiling debate really truly matters it
forces a real national discussion about
the real problem that this Nash that
this nation faced and that's
unrestrained government spending so do
not lose the focus no matter what you
hear on this real problem the real
problem is that unconstrained government
spending has put this country on an
unsustainable path the real problem is
that if Congress doesn't address this
chronic appetite for spinning right the
path will lead to fiscal ruin the real
problem is that the federal government
spends too much money so today I would
like to to go over the following points
first the debt ceiling which was put in
place for Congress to assert its mandate
to control spending has completely
failed I mean second whether we like it
or not the debt ceiling will have to be
raised because they just simply aren't
any budget out there that have been
proposed that do not require to raise
the amount of boring by the federal
government at least in the short run
third default would be a terrible option
it actually should not be on the table
however raising the debt ceiling with
that addressing the real problem of
chronic overspending is at least as bad
in the short term and far far worse in
the long term Congress should not take a
bad deal under false pretenses fourth I
have great news for you today taking a
bad deal or defaulting on our debt are
not the only options available
Congress right now it's not very often
that people you know show up in front of
you and give you good news right there
are many things I mean they're not
necessarily easy things but there are
many many things that actually Treasury
can do to avoid a default until Congress
actually reaches a deal or an agreement
that puts this country on a different
path finally whatever deal Congress and
lawmakers agree to make this is a deal
that needs absolutely to signal to our
investors that the United States is
addressing again its chronic problem of
overspending and it's taking solid steps
real solid step right in putting in
fiscal health in order probably through
I mean and we'll go through this I'll
show that actually through institutional
reform is probably the best way so now a
brief history of the debt ceiling so the
debt ceiling was first put in place in
1917 right as part as as a bill to
borrow more money to fund the First
World War right and the idea was by
limiting the authority that the
government had to borrow more money and
more importantly part by getting
Congress to go and ask for the
permission to borrow more money when
once we hit that limit that would
actually kind of command some
accountability on a factor on the part
of lawmakers unfortunately as we know
today the debt ceiling and its original
intended mission is completely failed
since it was put in place the government
has raised the debt ceiling almost a
hundred times in the last ten years as
you can see in this chart the debt
ceiling has been raised ten times
sometimes twice in one year that's where
you have you know the little triangles
so basically it has not worked
do you want to put the second however
unfortunately I am certain as I've said
that the debt ceiling will have to be
raised at least one more time as I said
it's because they just aren't any plans
out there that doesn't require for the
federal government to borrow more money
not chairman Ryan's plan not the
Republican Study committee's plan and
obviously not President Obama's plan
which in his budget showed an increase
in the debt held by the public doubling
from nine trillion dollars to 18
trillion dollars in the next ten years
and that goes to the core of our problem
Republicans and Democrats alike are
addicted to spending as this chart shows
it's the explosion in spinning not the
lack of revenue that are created the
gigantic fiscal imbalance that we suffer
from today and it is a gigantic
explosion in auto pilot programs such as
Medicare Medicaid and Social Security
that makes this gap bigger and bigger as
time goes by now the concern as you know
because you if you read the newspaper
that's all we hear about the concerning
the threat is that if we do not raise
the debt ceiling the government will
have to default on its debt come August
second right so again let me be clear I
really think that a devil should not be
an option it would be very very serious
if the US had to default on its debt
however it would be just as
irresponsible for Congress to continue
to increase raise the debt ceiling
without putting in place credible plans
to reduce its pending and future
government spending I mean that's what
they've been doing the last what 80
years and thinking that doing the same
thing over and over again we
we bring about different result is what
is the definition of vicinity right and
why is it that it's so important and
that's because investors are investors I
mean we always hear right I mean the
fear is that investors are going to
freak out if we don't raise the debt
ceiling because they're going to be
afraid we're going to default and not
pay their bill but the truth is
investors they're not just concerned
about whether we're going to be able to
pay our debt today whether we're going
to be able to pay our debt on August
second on august third in a month or in
a year they're actually concerned about
whether we're going to be able to pay
our debt today past august third in
three years and five years and ten years
and then when we pay these bills that we
pay them with a currency that actually
worth something that's important right
and why is it i mean because there are
three ways to pay down our debt there
are three ways cutting spending
increasing taxes or printing money I
mean what this debate is saying is
basically cutting spending and increased
taxes are not popular options and
investors really full well understand
that the third option is actually much
more political feasible not to mention
that it's been done before actually it's
been done the last two years a lot right
we can print out our debt a we can print
money and pay down our debt this way so
what do investors do when they fear this
threat what they do is that they
actually asked for an inflation premium
and that means you know an increasing
interest rate so make no mistakes the
biggest threat to the United States
long-term fiscal security is not whether
the debt ceiling increase happens today
tomorrow in August or later but whether
lawmakers again I really want to stress
this point because it is a point that is
really you rarely read about this in the
newspaper whether lawmaker put in place
credible plan to reduce their common
practice of boring fonts to pay for
their daily expenses I mean you don't do
this I don't do this but that's what
they do
and continue a sad record of
unsustainable spending investors will be
watching to see in the investors put
these measure in place before the auto
pilot program of Social Security
Medicare Medicare explode and with them
interest on our debt and start consuming
a larger and larger and larger part of
our resources so in that context let me
say something which again we haven't
heard very much even though it is
starting actually to make its way in the
media the date of August second which is
supposedly the day of our imminent
default right is someone arbitrary the
world you will remember right did not
come to an end on May sixteenth which
was the latest date where we were
supposed to hit the debt ceiling and we
were going to sorry you were we were
going to hit the debt ceiling and in the
same way comes on a second the world
will not come to an end contrary to what
you hear there is a world a world of
difference between hitting the debt
ceiling and defaulting on our debt I
know maybe come as a surprise because
when you are when you hear about this
when you are when you hear the date of
August second and hitting the debt
ceiling you have this everyone makes the
assumption that it means inevitably
we're going to default and this is the
great news so by the way this table
shows you the last four times Treasury
Geithner like oh the last four days the
Treasury Geithner has told us we were
going to default if we didn't
immediately raise the debt ceiling right
and the latest one is August second so
the great news we don't have to default
on our debt sure there is no way to wait
or to continue the brinksmanship of the
past few weeks but if more time is
necessary
I'd like to stress this sentence if more
time is necessary Treasury Geithner and
the Treasury Department has some option
that it can use to avoid a default until
we reach a deal that is acceptable
acceptable not politically acceptable in
order to put America back on track so
first Treasury can take some financial
steps right the extraordinary measure
I'm sorry this is a really hard word for
me to say with my French mouth so I'm
not going to say it again you know I'm
going to spare you so there are things
that can do it can do and it and in fact
this is how you know it's been able to
basically move these dates some of the
things you can do and is doing right now
is basically stopped for instance
putting money in the federal employees
pension trust fund it can also borrow it
basically can have the Federal Reserve
to some extent borrow money for Treasury
because that doesn't essentially count
against the debt ceiling there's a bunch
of things like this that it can do
second and Treasury can prioritize its
payment I mean that's what we do as
families we have budgets and we know
many of your students you have student
loans you have to buy food you have your
movie budget if you you know if you're a
family you have a house a mortgage
payment you have college tuition you
have all of that stuff right and we know
basically that in order I mean I know in
my case not to get in big trouble when
financial times are hard no matter what
I do I need to continue paying my
mortgage what is the same with Treasury
it's the same with Treasury a technical
default means
basically the Treasury Department stops
or fails to pay interest on our debt and
the principal that's come to and as you
can see on this chart in 2011 the
federal government will be collecting
overall 2.2 trillion dollars we have a
commitment of 3.7 trillion dollars which
kind of is where like our little problem
you know amazed right but what we know
is it with those two point two trillion
dollars right there's more than enough
to pay all the interest in our debt for
the entire year of 2011 and that's
roughly two hundred fifteen billion
dollars right that's enough and that
guarantees that we avoid any technical
default the good uses we can also have
we also have enough money to pay all of
social security benefit Medicare and
Medicaid and even we have four hundred
billion dollars left over to pay to pay
for military salaries or what what is
important to know by the way is a
Treasury Geithner has the authority to
prioritize payment it has this authority
what does it mean for today right this
is for 2011 from what i read recently
the treasury will be collecting until
the end of the fiscal year that's
September 30 years another 172 billion
dollars and the remainder of the
interests that are doing our debt is
roughly twenty nine billion dollars and
that means that there's still more money
to pay for other priorities whatever
they may be so that's an option it does
mean of course that if revenue were the
only thing available to Treasury we
would have to engage in dramatic
spending cuts but here's the second good
news of this talk who say it was a
pessimist there's more than this I mean
don't get me wrong I
mol in favor of cutting spending but
that's the other argument that you hear
all the time right is like oh well it's
horrible not paying any of our bill is
in effect a default but we don't have to
not pay all over all of our bills these
are commitments have been made fine
Treasury has assets that it can actually
sense that it can actually used to pay
the rest of its bill my colleague Jason
Victor and I we've actually put together
a very very very conservative list of
the assets that are available for
Treasury to use to actually continue
paying our bills I'm not talking about
selling real estate or a grills
greek-style private station here I'm not
saying you know they're just that sale
union station you know kind of sound
like a good idea but that's not what I'm
talking about I'm talking about how
about we sell our tarp assets wouldn't
that seemed like a good idea on the book
there's roughly a hundred seventy
billion dollars of such assets Treasury
also has non restricted cash on hand for
the amount of a hundred thirteen billion
dollars and there are other type of
things there's gold and which are valued
on the book you know at 42 dollars an
ounce which obviously is not necessarily
its current value I mean even though I
recognize it once the u.s. start dumping
its gold you know its price is likely to
go down however you know for all the
people who are saying you know well if
you start selling your assets now I mean
no one is going to actually buy them to
you at the price that they're on the
book they're going to play hardball but
isn't that a better option isn't that a
better option than actually defaulting
on our debt and by the way I do a good I
mean I do agree I mean these are not
good options I mean in a perfect world
you know in a perfect world it would be
better to liquidate the assets when it's
the most convenient for us
perfect world would rather be able as a
family to pay all of our bill without
having to tap into our savings but this
is not a perfect world it is a world
where lawmakers make decisions to spend
more and more money than they actually
have and I'm not even going to comment
on what they're spending it on so
selling these assets are not necessarily
a desirable option however it beats
defaulting on our debt you know and it
gives more time for Congress and the
president to work out a deal to raise
the debt ceiling in exchange for future
spending constraints which is what we
need raising the debt ceiling without
serious commitment to changing the
fiscal path that this country is on will
signal to investors at Treasury debt is
riskier after we raise the debt ceiling
then before we raised it it doesn't seem
like a good deal to me right and and
anyone who actually thinks about it a
little bit I mean would kind of
understand that this makes sense even
though again remember what we hear all
of the time is that investors are going
to be worried if we raise the debt
ceiling if we don't raise the debt
ceiling basically if we don't continue
borrowing more so it's true that if we
have to sell these assets right it's
possible I mean it's possible that
investors are going to are going to just
you know kind of say well maybe you know
we need to require some summer it's a
higher interest rate but if we raise the
debt ceiling without selling any of
these assets if we raise the debt
ceiling without a serious commitment to
this country and to investors and future
investors we are sure that interest
rates are going to actually raise go up
quite dramatically we I mean we know
that I mean
you know I've been reading a lot of the
academic literature I mean for instance
like a carmen reinhart and kenneth
rogoff I'm in their latest paper I mean
these guys are actually very they've
written many fascinating papers that
were been reviewed and much talked about
because they've showed that basically
looking at 200 countries over a long
period of time that basically there is a
point where when Deb becomes as a ratio
as a share of GDP becomes big enough
then the economy starts to collapse of
course it makes sense and in one of
their latest paper called a decade of
date debt they actually make the case
that absolutely when a country is on
track historically to have debt and debt
ended and that what happens is interest
rates go up and they can go up very
erratically overnight but they do go up
interestingly in their paper they never
ever talk about how interest rates an
investor freaked out because a country
is trying to actually put this house in
order so while bond investors seems to
shrug off brinksmanship in the short run
they're likely to stop not being worried
about the u.s. in the long run so
reducing spending and putting this these
reform in place would be really
important first to give us some cash but
also to send the signal to investors
that we're doing the right thing and
more importantly for all of us right it
would be important because it means our
country is getting back on track so what
is the real solution the real solution
are spending cuts and true institutional
reform right i mean i've talked about
how the only reason why we have a debt
ceiling crisis right now is because of
overspending by Republicans and
Democrats alike over the last 10 years
20 years 30 years right and while I you
know I applaud the talk about
ending cuts packages that we hear about
you here four trillion dollars two
trillion dollars I mean we've been down
that road before I mean spending
packages or are you know deal packages
with like large spending cuts and also
tax increases we know where that goes
usually those spending cuts they're
hardly real usually in our you know and
and and in the best case scenario
they're cut in the growth of spending
and or in the worst case scenario they
don't even happen and yet we're stuck
with the revenue increase so that's why
instead of getting this one-time
spending cut we all are not real I think
it would be way more important to put in
place institutional reforms that
actually really changes the way things
are done in Washington and ties the
hands of Congress and lawmakers so what
kind of institutional reforms do I talk
about well ideally very strict and
strong budget caps right and things with
that budget rules that actually bite
that can't be really overturned the
problem with these type of caps while
they sound good is that they can't
really constraint the hands of future
Congress's right I mean we've seen it
before something I've studied a lot is
the abuse of the emergency spending
system I mean and they were actually
strong supposedly strong budget rules
that were put in place so the emergency
emergency bills and emergency spending
wouldn't happen without having to offset
the spending or or for spending that was
actually not an emergency well years
after years Congress have let those
rules expire and in 2002 basically the
last of the rule that constraint the use
of emergency spending was expired and
then we got you know a gigantic abuse in
the last ten years so
I think that one of the thing that would
actually matter is to have some sort of
constitutional amendment to constrain
once and for all the ability of
congress's and administration to put us
on a path that leads to our fiscal ruin
thanks to the wisdom of the founders our
Constitution has a system of checks and
balances so let us suppose that thanks
to this constitution after we change it
and reform it every man is no longer a
knave but instead a statesman even
before death the debt crisis gives every
lawmaker in this country an opportunity
to restore some limits and constraint on
government and less appetite for
spending the United States needs some
urgent spending and institutional reform
there is enough expected tax revenue and
assets right as I explained on hand to
avoid the unattractive options of
defaulting on our debt right so let's
use it and let make sure that we get a
deal a real deal Congress in the
administration have time to work out
that deal as I've explained and that
would yes you know lead to an increase
in the debt ceiling in the short run but
more importantly it needs to be a deal
that would reduce spending and institute
reform that would shrink the deficit and
get the nation spending and debt under
control what we want is a deal that
solves problems not adds new problems
like all the deals we've had before and
then I'll take all your questions
so so I've left a lot of the details
please yep is what the Republicans are
falling Cut Cap and balance with a
balanced budget
the real problem anywhere that I did
that no one hundred I think certainly
that proposal it's going in the right
direction and is actually underlying the
right principles of a possible deal that
needs to be stripe my only concern
always with lawmakers that I want to
read the fine lines right and right now
it's a talking point you know Cut Cap
and balance and I haven't seen what I
want to see is like basically you know
where where will that what will
concretely these rules look like and
will they actually really tie the hands
of Congress but I think these are the
right principles does it have a chance
to pass you know I think the political
reality and you know when people say
it's not politically feasible this is a
very relative term maybe it's not
politically feasible right now but who
says that it's not in six months who
says it's not in a year so i don't know
i mean i don't i don't understand
Washington I don't understand what drive
these guys but I hope that it's possible
especially if those rules that they put
in our actually binding yes
doesn't that also allow for increasing
spending because if you have a budget
that spends more than last year's well
then all you have to do is raise taxes
to balance it off at least that's my
understanding of how that went so it
could be wrong it's a very good question
so I have you know I have mixed feelings
about budget budget amendments
constitutional amendment and one is I
again how is it designed because you can
balance the budget that eighty percent
of GDP and you know we wouldn't want
that right however while I and I and I
agree with you right on paper when you
have to have a balanced budget you can
actually lawmakers will inevitably
inevitably say listen we're not going to
cut all this and we need to raise
revenue in order in order to balance the
budget the problem is that in the end
you can raise taxes and it's not
necessarily obvious that you're going to
actually be able to raise the revenue
that you want to raise while it may look
like it on paper one of the things to be
no from the last 40 years or even longer
is that no matter how high marginal
interest rates have been right you know
ninety percent 35-percent the federal
government has failed to actually raise
much more than ninety percent of GDP in
revenue for more than a year or two
right so when you actually have a budget
balance amendment in place right on
paper they can say this is the route
we're going to go but at the end of the
at the end of the day they don't manage
to actually raise at revenue they're
going to have to kind of meet that
requirement and cut spending so I mean I
am
with you I mean there's a lot of things
that I worry about but I i do also say
see it as something that can be
extremely useful especially if it's
designed well you know yeah because
obviously the deficit problem comes from
the growth of government so to limit the
growth of government you do singlish
like a constitutional amendment that
would limit to just single issue bills
instead of throwing millions of things
in these bills I mean it seems to me it
seems like a pretty reasonable idea you
know I don't know about this first I'm
not an expert on this issue but i would
i would recommend that you actually go
on the market is website and look at the
work of a David primo who is a professor
at Rochester he's written first a
fantastic book about about institutional
rules that actually tends to constrain
government and he is written shorter
paper there you can find on our website
and basically he is thought very
thoroughly about what are the condition
and and and the type of rules that you
need to actually really effectively tie
budget hands so I'm not I mean it sounds
like a good idea I am sure the Primo and
by the way i'm sure you can also contact
him and ask him questions primo will be
able to answer your question yep sorry
yep
paid part of the participants and in
other words the long-term good health of
the country in this case is it possible
that there some of the participants all
this actually want a disaster say a
default that they can then blame on the
other party are there some people that
perhaps value their own political future
more than they value the long-term
health of the country it's all I mean
it's always possible I mean I can't
obviously judge intent of people I want
to believe that you know it's not the
case I can't judge intent one of the
things however that I can tell you is
I'm somewhat worried about the way both
sides talk about this debate because
even even on the more free market we
want to restrain government spending
side right there is this underlying
assumption that comes August second the
world is going to hell right and that
means that basically it doesn't give
much of an incentive for Treasury to
actually really do everything they can
to avoid a default and one of the things
that have been saying is what the reason
why it is actually risky to actually
continue talking about August second as
if this is like the date where we're
we're going to default is it basically
if there is such intention among anyone
with power and the administration they
get the cover that everyone knew that on
August second things were going to go
bad and the good news honestly is as I
said Justin figma and I we've been not
talking a lot about these issues and
about all the options that we have and
about the fact that this August second
date was somewhat arbitrary and now you
see it more and more in actually
newspaper there was actually an article
in The Washington Post there's this guy
Glenn Kessler who does a
as a column called a fact checker and
he's you know he's not necessarily a
raging free-market person but he's
really well-intentioned and he does his
work very seriously and in in this
column he said obviously August second
is not set in stone and you start
hearing this more and more and that I
think is good news very briefly on
what's happening in China right now and
how they're trying to seriously avoid a
recession and how maybe that is a bigger
issue to talk about rather than
necessarily our impending doom if Argost
second hits without a debt ceiling I
mean I think it's a pretty um and I
think it's a pretty a very good point
you know one of the reasons why
investors are not too worried about
America right now is because all their
eyes on Europe right i mean the european
crisis is actually really bad and it was
a long time coming it's kind of like i
don't want to be like I've told you so
in fact you know I actually moved away
from Europe
because I knew is coming but so that is
actually kind of investors losing a
rated country on a curve so as long as
we're you know not the ugliest one at
the beauty pageant we're fine but we're
really not that fine because we are in a
global economy and there's a very big
risk that if Europe just goes down
through basically content contagious
contagion from you know Greece to
Portugal Italy Spain Ireland and all
these other country it will reach us and
then there's a China issue I've actually
been thinking that one of the reasons
why you know for the longest time
economists have had never been able to
actually really show a connection
between the size of our deficit and
level of interest rates and one of the
reasons is because so far right so far
there's been enough capital flowing in
right so that actually we can't see the
connection but what happens once once
actually the amount of capital flowing
to our country not necessarily stops but
actually slows down you know we will
start seeing I mean consequences and
that main consequences will be an
increase in interest rates and China
right owns a lot of our debt and is also
sent sends a lot of psycho so 1 trillion
out of the four trillion roughly four
trillion debt that we have that we owe
to foreigners comes from China maybe a
little bit more and what happens if in
fact they hit a recession and it means
that they can't send as much money our
way so I mean I do worry about this you
know the other thing by the way about
China is like as you've heard I mean
there is a
chance that the u.s. long-term fiscal
health doesn't look too good right and
one of the things that we can see is
when you have like the biggest bond
holder like pemko for instance basically
turning its long-term debt into
short-term debt and when China is doing
it in Russia is doing it you know that
things are not looking too good for the
future does that answer your question
I'm going to go a little there and I'll
come back yes Thank You Veronique the
focus on the debt crisis i think
highlights the longer term leases I see
it drift towards in the United States a
more European style reliance on
government socialism you have thoughts
first on whether 20 years from now
separate from dealing with this debt
crisis that politically were as a
society we're going to be more like
you're without due respect you're all
your homeland and in Europe or more like
an America of passes rate as it comes to
fiscal responsibility and relatedly do
you have any observations even if
anecdotal about what you have seen in
France in your life and elsewhere in
Europe as to how through that reliance
on government and the confess kotori tax
policies that actual entrepreneurialism
is affected negatively and that society
lives differently that's what we talked
about here at least I do with others
theoretically but what have you observed
with your own eyes thank you so there's
a lot in there and first I would like to
tell you that I really did not want
America to end up like France because it
would be even worse because it would be
like gigantic government and no stinky
cheese
and I'm pasteurized milk and I would
have to be forced to shower every day no
it's not possible it's not an option and
this is why I'm fighting this is I mean
this is the fight my friends so we don't
end up like this but one of the things
you have to understand about Europe what
is it about Europe right it's I mean so
they think they're more generous and
things like this but really the defining
criteria about European governments no
matter and some are worse obviously than
others it is the fact that a gigantic
share of the population actually depends
on government spending or not
necessarily depends but receives some
government spending the French obviously
everyone gets something from the
government through free education
healthcare everyone no matter what your
level of income is right you get
something back if you're wealthy and you
have three kids you get a whole lot of
things and there's there's the whole and
so far and so you can imagine when most
people get something from the government
even though it actually is a terrible
deal because what they get is nothing
compared to what they pay not only
through their taxes but through slow
rate lower standards of living higher
prices high unemployment right it's
harder to change things because there's
so many people who are reluctant to
change whatever it is that no for
something that they don't know and
what's what's was very different in
America what is very different in
America is in addition to actually have
a philosophy that actually does truly
believe in individualism responsibility
entrepreneurship and things like this
there were also fewer much fewer people
who actually you depend or receive
government services at least at the
federal level is true
and during the recession one of the
thing that I was really worried about is
when when I was reading stories about
how you know more than half of state's
budget now were were made of you know
spin I mean basically transfer from the
federal government and also when I was
reading stories about a growing number
of Americans actually I think it's fifty
percent now you know or actually getting
something from the federal government
well it's even theirs theirs yet so
there's forty seven percent of American
filers who actually don't pay the income
tax but that I mean first most of them
was exceptions are very poor and that's
because Congress one after the other is
decided to distribute social benefits
through the tax code when you actually
when you actually and again you know
much fewer people don't pay the payroll
tax and then almost everyone acceptance
in lucky states where there's no sales
tax pay the sales tax so I mean this is
what I really worried about is basically
you know creating these bills you know
the health care bill basically that
basically that starts like actually you
know increasing the number of people who
actually get something even if it's even
if it's a bad deal you know because you
just kind of like it makes you basically
someone who may be reluctant to give up
what it is you have and yes i can tell
you my own experience certainly i mean
just in France I mean very high
unemployment at least at the time where
I was there it went down but it's still
true like for women for young people
very hard it's very hard to start a
business and one of the reasons is
because you have to jump through a lot
of regulatory hopes but also you know
before you start to have all these
social taxes that you have to pay even
before you start making a dime and their
way higher I'm much more expensive than
there are in America but I think more
dramatically to me is the inability to
think outside of the box and knew not to
actually think that the government is
the answer to everything don't ask me
how I was so different there my parents
would always look at me and say like how
did we fail you know and it was just
like but you know so yeah I mean so I
have I mean I've seen you know I've seen
my uncle you know because the problem in
France for instance is when you one of
the I mean right now things are like
different but I mean one of the
recurring thing about unemployment and
France not only was it higher right but
when you're unemployed you stayed
unemployed you stayed unemployed I know
and for the longest time American had
black unemployment rates that were much
lower but also the time where people
would say it would be an employer was
actually much much shorter so yeah I
think it's just uh it's you know this is
my fear of this is the fight you know I
didn't think I was coming here to fight
that fight all over again but here I am
there's a dude a question this will be
our last question really oh yeah there
were reports from unnamed officials in
the Obama administration that he is
considering using the 14th amendment to
argue that the credit of the United
States has to be respected and therefore
continue to spend even if Congress
doesn't pass any kind of spending bill
I'm just wondering what you thought of
that argument and how Congress should
react to it ok so again you know I'm an
economist I am NOT a lawyer but if you
were interested actually in this issue
you should go to the Warlock conspiracy
and look at the writing by Jonathan
Adler I mean that's pretty much where I
know what I know about this issue and
and also one of my daughter's friend
heard her dad actually 10 years ago
wrote a law review article about how
actually it is unconstitutional prob
probably I guess because lawyers always
kind of like probably everything right
to default and what handler Adler is
saying is if anything with that Clause
means is that the president has an
obligation to use to use everything in
their power to make sure we don't
default right I mean so that's I mean I
can't but I can't tell you like the in
and out of the whole thing but i would
recommend you go and read what edler has
said and and and if in fact really i
mean it's unconstitutional to default
this 14th amendment of section 4 is
actually about how like if that's the
case then we shouldn't even be having
this conversation about and by the way
that leads me to my last point one of
the things that really actually makes me
unbelievably mad right now and all the
people who actually come back to me and
say well selling assets is really hard
yeah it is hard or say well you know all
these assets on the book because it's
going to be a fire sale we're not going
to get the value we have on those books
I'm like yeah sure better than a default
and by the way what were you doing six
months ago not selling these assets
already to actually pretend prevent as
being in this quite dramatic situation
today this is I mean absolute utterly
failure of leadership by the way I mean
I will put it out there I mean this is
democratic failure I have no faith that
if we had been in the same situation
with Republicans we would have had
better leadership on this issue because
I actually think that lawmakers did
don't sink in long terms you know in the
long term and and and the actual really
well being financial safety of this
country we wouldn't be in the situation
in the first place we wouldn't have had
like this gigantic increase in spending
in the last ten years sixty percent
adjusted for inflation under President
Bush I mean we wouldn't be here if
actually lawmakers really you know got
it so I mean that actually really makes
me extremely mad thank you thank you